I think a lot of women feel pressure to
have kids especially when you get
engaged and once the wedding and when
you can have babies and for me I'm like
I don't want that pressure on myself
bachelor nation was abuzz with baby
rumors when this photo of Kaitlyn
Bristowe and fellow former bachelor
contestant Whitney Bischoff appeared on
Instagram Sunday but Caitlin was quick
to set the record straight tweeting no
I'm freezing my eggs and giving them to
Whitney and OVA to babysit over egg
freezing the fertility clinic has given
her peace of mind and allowed her to
quote take control of my future this is
kind of a back-up plan for us and for us
to feel comfortable kind of like
insurance Caitlin's fiance Sean Booth
has supported her throughout the process
posting this photo to Instagram post
procedure with the caption always
impressed by her strength and courage
but even more so after these past few
weeks very proud of her for taking
control of our future and if you thought
freezing her eggs meant Kaitlyn wants a
small family we always say one have
probably five but we'll talk after we
have one yeah a favorite
[Music]